[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
tonight our piers morgan uncensored her
majesty's final journey the late queen's
coffin makes it way to buckingham palace
millions are expected to see her lion
state
harry is banned from wearing military
uniform at the vigil disgraced prince
andrew can wear his full regalia how can
that be right
plus ukraine punches back putin's war is
in disarray but how deadly will his
counter-strike possibly be
live from london this is piers morgan
uncensored
well good evening i'm pierce morgan it's
gonna be a very emotional night tonight
as i speak the hearse carrying the late
queen elizabeth ii
is moving slowly from north halt
in west london to buckingham palace
of course her world famous residence is
the last time
that the queen's body will ever be at
the palace she'll be there overnight and
then she'll be moved to lyon state
members of the royal family are going to
be at the palace to greet her and she'll
be arriving sometime in the next few
minutes and will of course bring you
that news when we get it but it's been a
really moving day
from the very morning that it all
started up in scotland of course where
she'd been lying estate at giles
cathedral in edinburgh she was then
taken by the raf by plane
down to northhold and tonight her coffee
will lie in rest in the bow room where
she greeted countless visiting heads of
state and tomorrow she lion stayed at
westminster hall where millions
potentially are expected to come and try
to see her many of them queueing
overnight
well i'm joined now by talking to these
photographer captain cat and talk to the
royal editor sarah houston let's start
with you sarah you're down there at
buckingham palace
waiting for what is going to be a truly
historic and emotional moment isn't it
this is the great queen arguably the
greatest of all queens
going back to buckingham palace the sort
of epicenter of the royal family to the
world
for the last time
yes and pierce what's really striking as
i stand here
is how quiet it is there is a huge crowd
that has gathered
to witness the queen's final journey in
through those famous gates of buckingham
palace
and yet they are standing there in
silence umbrellas are waiting quietly
they've been waiting for some time now
many of them queued for hours to get a
position to see this moment in history
the atmosphere is incredibly sombre
i've been here throughout the week at
piers and
the atmosphere's changed from day to day
but today
you just feel that mood has come down
that people are hearing quiet reflection
waiting for this moment to say goodbye
to the queen
and she will shortly be driven through
those gates of buckingham palace into
her official london residence that home
that is
so associated
with the monarchy and the crown
and the queen and there she will rest in
the bow room at buckingham palace until
tomorrow
when at 2 22 she will make her way
on a gun carriage slowly through the
streets of london to westminster hall to
lyon state and allow more people to pay
their respects
so um sarah i mean i was coming into
work here in healing and west london
and i couldn't work out why the traffic
was so bad and then i looked at is
pouring the rain i looked at i just saw
the streets were lined with people and
police and i suddenly realized this was
the route
from northult into
the center of london into buckingham
palace and there were so many people
uh and so many police and everyone was
very quiet everyone was very respectful
but it was chucking it down with rain
and it was a very poignant scene
actually that so many people so many of
the queen's subjects
uh were just waiting quietly we're
seeing now
a live footage here actually of the
hearse arriving at buckingham palace
this is her majesty queen elizabeth ii
this is her final journey but back to
buckingham palace tonight
uh thousands of people
there outside the palace waiting for
this
and there is the hearse
and she'll be greeted we understand by
all of the senior royals pretty much her
children
and her grandchildren and their wives
and i think uh some neat nieces and
nephews as well
and they'll be greeting this remarkable
woman at the palace for the last time
and she'll spend the night there
and then tomorrow the public will get
their chance to pay their respects as
the people in scotland of course have
been doing
the last two days
but it's it's pretty poignant this isn't
it this is a remarkable moment
involving this extraordinary woman
it's very hard not to be very moved by
this before well now the crowd are
bursting into spontaneous applause
as that purse passed by
um
it sent a shiver down my spine it it
really is quite a moment the atmosphere
here it's it's hard to describe
as that hurst drove through in the
darkness
in the rain
and the queen making her final journey
and of course there have been so many
moments over the course of the past
couple of days from balmoral to
edinburgh today from edinburgh
to london and now this journey from raf
northalt to buckingham palace
okay sarah well listen
we'll keep a watch on that we'll see
what happens over the next few minutes
see if we can see uh the hurst being met
by members of the family i want to go
down to kate mccann is in westminster
kate obviously the queen will spend this
last night
at her great palace and then tomorrow
she'll move to westminster abbey where
she will lie in state for four days and
some people have been queueing all day
already just to get the chance to walk
past and have their few seconds
uh a few feet away from her majesty
what's it been like down there
yeah the mood in westminster is a really
interesting one in some parts of
westminster there is really frenzied
activity preparing for what will be a
huge influx of people who want to come
and pay their last respects and then at
the queueing sites where people are
already starting to set up those tents
some of them have gazebos everybody kind
of coming together in not quite a
celebratory mood but a somber one whilst
at the same time knowing that what they
are witnessing is a real moment in
history and they are they are really
incredible royal fans the people who are
already there they are in the rain it is
pretty miserable it's on the side of the
river there's not a lot down there but
there will be peers because there is a
huge plan to make sure that all those
many thousands of people maybe as many
as a million who decide to queue over
the next couple of days we'll be well
catered for there will be lose down
there there'll be access to food and
drink you'll get a wristband if you want
to leave that queue and the intention is
to try and get as many people through as
possible the atmosphere though inside
westminster hall that incredibly
historic part of the palace will be
still and crucially silent you won't be
allowed to take photos or videos and the
palace is asking people to dress in
somber clothing to reflect really the
sense of occasion that it will be inside
that palace when people go and pay their
last respects to the late queen right
and kate um meanwhile our new king has
continued his travels around the united
kingdom and today northern ireland um
that was a very significant trip wasn't
it
it was and it's interesting that we are
describing the mood at these occasions
because we know what the ceremony looks
like and we kind of know what some of
the formalities are but it's always the
mood that's fascinating and in northern
ireland today
that was one of the things that
everybody was holding their breath to
watch because there has been such huge
tension over time in that part of the
world and remember the queen played such
a significant role
in really trying to ease some of that
pressure and tension in 2011 and 2012
shaking hands with martin mcguinness for
example those were seen as crucial
moments that she was really the only
person who could who could make those
steps and move things forward and that
was really appreciated that soft power
if you like she didn't overstep she made
exactly the right move at exactly the
right time and i think there had been
some tension trying to understand
whether king charles will be able to do
the same thing and so that warning today
from the storm and speaker shin fans
alex maskey essentially one which towed
the line between saying we welcome you
here we are very happy to see you we
support you and we share in your grief
but also just remember the tensions here
and really how difficult it is to try
and unite all parts
in what will be a difficult period there
is no stormont assembly at the moment
there is a key issue around brexit and
the northern irish protocol
which is yet to be resolved and king
charles he's been there 40 times before
but of course never as king his first
visit which set the tone today he made
it very clear that he recognized the
power of the monarch what his queen had
done before him
and that he intends to follow in her
footsteps
kate mccann thank you very much indeed
well i'm joined now by former newspaper
editor emily sheffield uh talk tv's
legendary
contributor adam bolton and the chair of
the confederation and british industry
lord bill amore thank you very much
indeed uh all of you for coming a little
bit more let me start with you you knew
the royal family you've known
the queen
before she died you've known the new
king
and his queen consoled
what are your reflections on the last
few days yes just to clarify i'm past
president of the cbi
uh i i've been very lucky from my
earliest i was born and brought up in
india and my
father was uh a commander-in-chief of
the central army in india when he was a
young captain he was adc aided to comp
to the first president of india rajinder
prashad and their pictures my house from
my early memories including now if you
go to my house family house in india of
my father my mother with the queen with
the duke of edinburgh on the state visit
in 1961.
and little did i think that fast forward
and i would actually have the privilege
of not just meeting them but meeting
them many many times and getting to know
them
and as well as prince charles now king
charles iii
and it's been extraordinary and it's
been an amazing inspiration one of the
things that people don't talk about
enough is
uh the the devotion between the queen
and the duke of edinburgh
uh she used to refer to him as her rock
and i remember once coming out of the
zoroastrian party community which i'm a
patron of here in the uk one of the
tiniest minority communities in the
world
in harrow we went into the prayer room
with the duke of edinburgh had to take
our shoes off we came out of the prayer
room and we're both sitting next to each
other
tying our shoelaces and he turned around
to me said you know i've had these shoes
from the day i was married and that was
the sort of sentimentality that existed
between the two of them and sadly he
passed away last year and very soon
after that you know you saw her starting
to use a walking stick yeah i don't
think she ever really recovered from
philip actually so i've written a column
for the sun tonight about prince charles
i keep saying this everyone does don't
they uh king charles iii
about i've rarely seen any public figure
rise to such momentous occasion i don't
think in the way that he does
and as always you write a column like
that and it certainly it will stand the
test of time but there was a moment
today which i think just showed that
underneath this exterior which he's
putting on is a man that's just lost his
the mother he loved
coming so soon after the father that he
loved under enormous pressure to hit the
right tone and hit it running as our new
monarch and there was this moment where
he went to sign uh an official document
today with his ink pen
and this is how he reacted
to 12 13
[Music]
i mean this is for cbs news this footage
i mean i was surprised that we get to
see that actually i think he should have
been better protected but it was an
insight just into behind the the veneer
is a man who's under enormous pressure
both personally and professionally well
yesterday i was privileged to be in
westminster hall that was just being
spoken about this 900 year old hall one
of the oldest parts of this country i
mean along with windsor castle and the
tower of london uh you have westminster
and westminster abbey these are the
ancient parts of our country and he
spoke about that and how much it meant
to him
and with all of us lords and members of
parliament over there and you could see
how moved he was and actually i saw a
photograph today which showed that he
was in tears um during during that
occasion but emily that little snapshot
there of himself losing his temper about
a 40 pen
i just thought it just showed us that
beneath all this
there must be a torrent of emotions
raging inside this new king
i'm sure because he's he's probably also
exhausted
um what i was interested to get more
detail on today which was george bush's
daughter was over to interview him
um sorry was interview over here to
interview the new queen consort
and
clearly they were not expecting the
queen to pass away where my reading had
slightly been that because
our king had been with her all week that
they were concerned i think this really
did come as a shock i don't think they
were expected so he will also be
suffering still from the shock and you
don't i imagine the amount that he's
having to deal with and present himself
the speeches becoming king i doubt he's
had any time to i i don't like using the
word process but in a way as you see
he's not properly grieved
they're focused on this man
now and his his wife camilla
relentlessly from the second they appear
in public and they're having to appear
in public all the time whilst going
through what i would imagine is pretty
intense grief well i i agree with that
but on the other hand the reason why the
world's cameras are there is because
as the queen said you need to be seen
that these rituals that they're going
through visiting uh the four nations of
the country are important in terms of
establishing the monikers uh the head of
state of all the united kingdom and you
know
i'm afraid my reaction looking at that
footage
and i know
all the pressures that you've mentioned
and all the
undoubted genuine grief is my reaction
is the queen wouldn't have behaved like
that right and she
she would have made a joke of it and
well and she probably wouldn't have
actually had that happen in front of a
camera i mean that's the thing i'm
surprised that well that's not me
these signing
ceremonies
are part of the whole deal i mean that's
that's why they're taking place i mean
we saw i don't know whether the lord and
mourinho was there but at the accession
ceremony everyone who was there yes
signed a document in public and quite
long only cbs cameras were capturing
that moment and i'm just surprised we've
been able to see it because it does show
a moment away from what we're seeing he
loses but i i mean i'm afraid i do think
these
things
these instances these off-camera moments
can be quite revealing
i i want to talk uh if i may uh lord
billy
there's this issue about how far do you
go to show the queen
respect
in cancelling things there's been a
whole slew of things cancelled the
football was all cancelled at the
weekend but the cricket the racing the
golf all went on and showed a respectful
moment of silence and applause and then
moved on which i felt was the right way
to handle it um what do you think about
this center parks today for example
have suddenly decided they're gonna stop
everything on monday on the day of the
funeral and remove every family who's on
the holiday there and tell them they've
got to leave which seems to me
completely outrageous and the very last
thing
that her majesty would have wanted
what what has happened over here is
you've got a figure
that
has sort of risen above all other people
in the world in many ways for 70 years
and you've got this individual's monarch
of all monarchs a queen of all queens
that is not just the most famous monarch
in the world but the most respected i
mean i've received messages from every
corner
so i'm saying that people that if you
look at look at the sentiment that
people are expressing look at the people
who started queueing to pay respects in
westminster hall from yesterday i
remember yesterday when i went to swear
my oath i was told one of the peer
sectors people are starting but when you
have a massive holiday company with a
load of people who've paid good money
and they're told they have to leave
all these parks around the country i
think that is a ridiculous way of
supposedly showing the queen restaurant
i think what you're seeing is is
companies
frankly using is a bit of an excuse i
mean i've had two of those you know
those things when you phone up you get a
recorded message two of them saying oh
we can't get your message today because
of the circumstances and you know we
know people i think it was in norwich
uh closed bicycle parking spaces as much
well
food banks in wimbledon are being closed
on monday yeah and that caused outrage
people saying let me get this straight
we're going to be shutting down food
banks for the most desperate hungry
people in the country
whilst at the same time the reason given
is because there's a funeral for one of
the richest the only thing i would say
and i don't know whether quite how it
works out but
rightly it's been called a bank holding
on monday a day for everyone to show
their respect and i think some companies
may have contractual things with their
employees about them not being there at
bank holidays and all that kind of maybe
not wanting to be accused of not
allowing their employees to mourn their
queen emily i want to talk to you about
um princess anne he put out a statement
uh just before we came on air saying how
fortunate she felt to share the last 24
hours of my dearest mother's life it's
been an honor and a privilege to
accompany her on her final journeys
witnessing the love and respect shown by
so many omnichos has been both humbling
and uplifting we will all share unique
memories after my thanks to each and
every one who shares our sense of loss
and she then goes on to say that um she
offers uh very grateful for the support
and understanding of her dear brother
charles as he accepts the added
responsibilities of the monarch to my
mother the queen thank you i i do think
in many ways anne is the most like her
mother of all the other royals actually
and watching her following her mother's
hurts all around the country has been
incredibly moving i've i find just
watching incredibly moving i think if
you hear anyone talking about the royals
ann is the unsung heroine
she's the hardest working royal the
least celebrity she's the least
celebrity she works the hardest she
doesn't chase the media yeah she's never
got caught in any kind of scandal um
i mean there may have been some when she
was incredibly young but um
no one marriage now there's a second i
mean and her children are
exemplary so i think a lot of a lot of
people have a huge amount of affection
for princess anne she's i mean again i'm
lucky and privileged to see this
firsthand and her her private secretary
retired recently he always got the
hardest working boss in the world yeah
and it was real she worked really well i
think she's a real one
and that well you say i'm saying i mean
her title of princess royal was
recognition really no i know i just
don't think she ever gets the attention
that a lot of the other royals get and
she should get more attention i think
she's been she's not sure if she's that
keen on the attention
no no i think that's right yeah uh
little billy murray just quickly about
the economy everything's on hold this
week in terms of the economy and yet we
know that ticking away is a gigantic
financial crisis a huge energy crisis a
lot of uncertainty in ukraine i'm going
to talk about that a little later in the
program where it seems like ukrainians
are making
moves against the russians successfully
but what will that inspire from putin in
terms of retaliatory action all this
uncertainty will make things more
difficult financially for this country
what state are we in well actually if
you think about it right now what's
happened it's unprecedented
that last week you have a new prime
minister and a new monarch in one week
and what what a test of a country to see
how resilient you are that we all come
together and you have this amazing
transition that is taking place now
where we're all sad i mean we love the
queen and i'm sad actually but actually
if anything suspending everything for
ten days will make the economic
situation underneath all this worse
what this is showing is the advantage of
having a monarchy one of the biggest
advantages of a republic is you have
this continuity in somebody who's a
political object how does that help the
economy it helps economy in a big way
because you have this stability this
constance to steadfastness through that
figure but that won't pay the bills will
it it will help a lot it helps our
economy it helps our country the soft
power the soft power that the queen gave
our country with your own cbi president
how bad is the economic situation right
now in this country the economic
situation is dire i mean the bad as
you've ever seen the energy crisis it is
as bad because you've had two years of
pandemic then the sad war in ukraine its
crisis after crisis then the
unsettlement of brexit which started in
2016 so for six years in a row we've had
challenges that we've had to cope with
now i think the energy crisis the good
news as the government has said we're
going to have a cap for consumers
they've got a plan for businesses the
big issue is the government has realized
now that they helped during the pandemic
400 billion pounds
i kept saying don't stop you need to
keep healthy helping consumers and
businesses you can't suddenly say i have
no money and
list trust is saying the truth i think
she's on the right track absolutely
undergraduate focusing on growth
focusing on incentivizing investment
focusing on now saying i'm going to help
you the cap of 2500 pounds these are all
the right measures well billy murray
great to see you today thank you very
much you guys are coming back a little
later i think so stay with us coming
next prince harry has been banned from
wearing military uniform at this week's
ceremonies but disgrace prince andrew
apparently will be allowed to at least
one of them is it fair should we care
converting that with prince andre's
friend lady victoria hervey and the
author petronella wireless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to peacemaking session
whatever your views about prince harry's
treatment of his father our new king of
the royal family his military service is
beyond dispute 10 years in the british
army two tours of afghanistan he was a
war hero but harry won't be allowed to
wear military uniform a ceremonial
events marking made for his grandmother
late queen but zion's on the other hand
will be at at least one of the events a
vigil the duke will apparently don naval
attire for her final vigil in
westminster hall he of course did serve
in the falklands war but he also
recently paid a woman he claims he never
met
up to 10 million dollars
to make a court case involving alleged
sex abuse go away so the unpopular
prince
can't dress up but the disgraced duke
can
you might be amused as me as to where
the line is on this i'm joined now by
journalist north of petriah wyatt and
socialite and aristocat lady victoria
aristocrat lady victoria hardy welcome
to both of you it might be the poshest
panel i've ever had thanks uh i'm called
piers i'm the least person here um
what do you think lady victoria about i
don't understand it personally i've got
no truck with harry potter like an
imbecile most of the times however i
don't i don't begrudge him the right to
wear a military uniform after 10 years
serving his country and unlike his uncle
andrew he has not been involved in a
really disgraceful scandal but he he did
desert his country you know he left the
country yes but he he sort of decided he
basically wanted to completely leave
this country and go to america which is
the worst time and why do that when your
grandmother is the queen and she is in
her last years of her life but that's a
different argument to me okay the
argument is about that but why is he
allowed well what is that one of 10
years once of 20 years
um diff i mean one is destroyed and
wanna just behave quite badly i think
actually both of them should be allowed
to wear them because this is such a huge
event and i think everything should be
put aside and they should both be able
to translate well
first of all nobody's actually got to
the real point of this is
whose decision was it and i believe it
was the queen's decision
and this is what i'm hearing uh
technically
harry cannot wear it's actually against
the law for harry to wear military
uniform if it's a law yes
you can look it up yeah it's actually
against the law because he was stripped
of all his military titles
and veterans who are simply veterans
cannot wear military uniform so my
father who fought in the first world war
could not have worn a military uniform
it was very interesting when i tweeted i
thought harry should be allowed to a lot
of veterans actually did reply saying he
shouldn't
well technically he shouldn't that um
andrew was not
um
stripped of his military titles he was
sort of forced into retiring from him
i do feel a little bit sorry for harry
although
you know it's a different circumstances
you know andrew prince andrew did not
deserve his country and go and move to
america
a woman he says
that's not to say he didn't
about this is the ammunition it will
give to the megan brigade and all their
mad twitter supporters
and i think the story at the moment
should be
not about trivial issues
oprah winfrey popped up yesterday well
no because let me finish yeah she popped
up yesterday saying she hopes that the
family that this uh the death of the
queen can now heal the rift i mean
they're all
was dying in hospital while he was
literally dying they did the interview
yeah well they weren't aware that he was
actually dying
99 years old hospital
i think that's slightly irrelevant
i'm always in oprah's hypocrisy where
she says i hope they heal the rift
seriously
it's not only oppression it's american
hypocrisy because
the um a source on on the queen the
royal family itself is coming from
the now radical left new york times
which has hired a bunch of lefty
english journalists
um but
nobody in this country is listening to
them nobody but what we don't want at
this time are silly media stories about
riffs within the royal family well the
problem is there are actually risks in
the royal family
when
why did he tell you that
um i have sources right who knows but at
the moment they certainly do
is there any way back for andrew into
public life no to what happened
absolutely not you think they're right i
think gradually i don't think it's going
to happen overnight um gradually we will
be dead before it happens
he's not that up but i can't say why
would he be dead should he should he be
allowed no there's no public attack
how is someone like you who's a
journalist how can a journalist go and
tell someone in the royal family what to
do like what because
yeah victoria victoria gives you the
right we pay we pay for
them exactly
we pay for them you pay taxes you pay
for the royal family
when a journalist can go oh well he has
to do this like
don't talk over each other here's my
point the reason we're allowed to say
what we like about the royal family
actually is because we all pay taxes
here and that pays for them they live
off our money so of course we're allowed
to have an opinion about all of them
that's the whole point that goes with
the territory my issue about andrew is i
think that charles and william have
decided there's no way back for him
certainly for a long time and that may
be just the end of it
because i stopped guessing
i'm trying i want to tell you a story um
i mean um
about eight nine months ago the queen
gave andrew lump some money
uh because she understood perfectly yes
he was one of her favorite children but
she understood perfectly there's no
future for him under king charles
none whatsoever charles would never let
him back
um
william would never let him back there's
no return which is why she wants to make
sure he was financially secure
and what about okay
i'm sure that's right i just find it so
fascinating how like people at
newspapers seem to know
every little detail and
actually
no i know but it's like you it's like so
much of it it's made up yeah exactly so
much of it is just like a little fantasy
in your
hair
okay actually it's all fantastic a lot
of it gets a lot
how the amount that the junior was
supposedly paid it went from 10 minutes
let's be clear they went to three
minutes let's be clear andrew
andrew pays millions of dollars
inarguably to a woman he said he'd never
met yeah to make a civil case go away in
which she was accused of sexually
abusing her and that's why the british
public doesn't want him back he paid
millions of dollars three million three
million has not a lot of money to tell
victoria to go away
thank you both very much indeed for
joining me we're coming next uh ukraine
defies the odds again with a massive
counter-offensive his putin's war and
his regime now on the brink of collapse
defense experts on both sides of
atlantic and their say next one of the
wars we could be closer than ever to a
nuclear strike
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to baseball centre the
world's attention has quite rightly been
focused on the late queen it's a
momentous turning point in our history
and world history but while our eyes
have been temporarily averted something
extraordinary has been happening in
ukraine the ukrainians are defying the
odds again and before we talk more about
her majesty or anything else
sort of pay tribute to these ukrainians
because while we mourn our late queen
ukrainians are mourning their fathers
brothers sisters and daughters every
single day
as we come together to remember what
makes our country great ukrainians are
fighting and dying just to make sure
their country still exists exists next
year
thousands of ukrainians have been
liberated this week in a massive sucker
punch counter-attacking the south of the
east it's been quite remarkable many
said it couldn't be done the ukraine
just didn't have the numbers but in
tanks from trenches with brute force and
unimaginable bravery the russian flag is
being torn down ukraine has taken back
more than two thousand square miles of
his country this is the biggest turning
point in the war since putin's invaders
were battered away from kiev at the very
start of making a mistake
it's not the end nowhere near but it
does show yet again what remarkably
resilient people these ukrainians are is
crucial they can build up from a
position of this new strength so now
more than ever even though our thoughts
are rightly here and our late great
queen
we should remember
we must continue to back ukraine we must
give president zielinski what he needs
the late queen's coffin was carried to
london today on the same raf plane has
been used to deliver british weapons and
british aid to ukraine two very
different services of duty but both i
think equally important joining me now
to discuss that is ukraine it's former
u.s secretary of defense under president
trump mark esper and chair of the house
of commons defense select committee
tobias ellwood and here's my pack uh
brilliant back emily adam from earlier
so thank you for rejoining me uh to
myself but before we get to this i want
to ask you on the back of that last
debate this issue of prince harry and
andrew and whether they should be
allowed to wear military uniforms
during this week of of events in memory
of the queen what's your view of this
i don't have a strong view on that my
focus is on the
transition and making sure that we give
the king all the support uh is provided
some big decisions need to be made
leadership-wise on britain's place in
the world we have a new prime minister a
new king there's an absence of
leadership on the international stage
it's not really coming from america
we've been hesitant a little bit
risk-averse across the west now i just
want to focus on making sure that we
invest in our armed forces and as you
rightly point out do not forget what is
going on ukraine because it's moved into
a very very dangerous chapter you're
absolutely right to congratulate the
ukrainian forces uh putin made a
calculation that he thought the nation
would collapse when he invaded he was
absolutely wrong there but he was right
on assuming that the west would sit on
his hands that the west would not want
to get directly involved we've left
ukraine to do the fighting and now that
there's been this massive surge
incredible advance a counter-attack by
the ukrainians we must uh not kid
ourselves that somehow putin is defeated
this is his worst setback as a president
politically and militarily i suspect
he's going to come out fighting and it
could get very very ugly indeed all
right
dr mark esper i mean there's no doubt it
could there's also no doubt that what
has been happening in the last two or
three days in ukraine is quite
extraordinary
no that's right and first of all let me
echo your comments about the ukrainians
they have showed great skill and courage
and and grit in fighting the russians
and what i on the front lines of what i
think is the
is the autocracies versus democracies of
the 21st century so i think they've done
an outstanding job but you're right the
turnaround has been remarkable they've
uh they've shown great prowess on the
battlefield and look
putin is uh
his military has shown extreme
weaknesses from top to bottom and it's
been a great strategic failure on a
number of counts the question is can he
does he have any manpower and material
left to really push back hard against
the ukrainians because it they they
continue to deplete uh russian combat
capability right to buy someone just in
uh some news here ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky says 6 000 square
kilometers of territory have now been
seized back from russian occupied forces
that's a huge amount of territory that
they've regained and i've seen several
maps of that whole
southeast region the donbass and you can
just see great swathes of ukrainian
territory being taken back and russians
in apparent retreat
so they've got if they are going to
retaliate in the way that you you fear
they've got to get on with it haven't
they
uh yes well firstly it's pleasure to
share a platform with my friend uh mark
uh you're absolutely right to say how
would this retaliation take place this
is a textbook deception almost like the
d-day landings when we were pretending
to go to calais ended up in normandy and
nazis had moved troops from normandy up
to calais you know president zielinski
said he was going to kiss and down east
of odessa ends up in the north near
kharkiv and pushed through 30 miles in
coming close to the russian border and
the supply chains have collapsed the
russian morale is depleted poor
equipment as we've been discussing
ammunition's running low and so forth
but i make it very very clear putin is
in this for the long game this is part
of a wider strategy that we must get our
heads around we've moved into a new era
of insecurity so what happens in ukraine
today this month indeed this year is
actually part of a wider tapestry of
events that i think are going to unfold
in front of us he's meeting president xi
next week once again his key ally on the
international stage here no doubt we'll
ask him for support as well putin this
is his war of choice he can't afford to
lose it and he's going to come out
fighting don't trust the final word to
you on this do you think the ukrainians
can win this war and can they win it
quite quickly given what has been going
on
i absolutely absolutely think they can
win this war uh it won't be done quickly
you know they have they have great
momentum right now but they have to be
careful not to outrun their logistics
and their ability to secure their lines
of communication at some point the
russians will stop and dig in and and
defend but the broader strategic issues
are there as was just outlined you know
putin is going to reach out to xi
jinping is a strategic partner you see
some rumblings today in uh in armenia
where the azerbaijanis are pushing
against
russian partners maybe we'll see
something happen in georgia where
there's another frozen conflict there's
a much bigger geo strategic play here
going on got to leave it there dr esper
and tobias well thank you both very much
indeed appreciate it quickly to the pack
to your action i mean this is
would normally be the leading the news i
think this story understandably has been
slightly relegated because of what's
happening here but an extraordinary turn
of events in ukraine and when i was
there the resilience from these people
and determination not to give the
russians an inch was very palpable it
looks like they're carrying through on
what they told me well i think it's
both
both those experts pointed out it is
this is a great moment to celebrate what
they've done
but putin remains a formidable opponent
who can gather huge forces uh to hit
back at some point but i think this has
been an amazing thing for the ukrainians
morale because what's incredibly
important is their morale stays up and
the more wins they get even if they get
pushed back again or it you know that as
you said the war is not going to end
anytime soon keeping that morale
it reminds me a bit i mean you know
churchill's great quality was to
persuade the british public that we
could beat the nazis even when it
appeared we haven't got a chance you
feel that with zolensky a little bit i
certainly do that he has driven his
people to a mindset or they they believe
they can win well i think there's no
doubt that zelinski was the sort of
unforeseen factor in all this conflict
that he was seen as a bit of a joke
figure because he'd been a television
actor and all the rest of it
and he has absolutely risen to the
moment proved himself very skillful
communicator both to his own people and
to the rest of the world and he survived
so i i think all of that
is very important and it's also
important that he has come out with some
very very strong statements against
putin and effectively laid down the
conditions that he would accept which
are you know really saying get out of
crimea and get out of here i think it's
going to be a fascinating few weeks now
to see if they can keep this momentum
going because if they do and the
russians think they might be losing
putin himself his own position may come
into peril from his own side which is
what many people worry about is he may
be replaced by worse well of course
nationalist leader you can't keep not
doing things because you think worse may
happen you got to take him on at some
stage and i love what's happening at the
moment we're coming next the lake queen
is at buckingham palace for the final
time after being flown to london this
evening i talked to a pilot who used to
fly the royal family around the world
next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my next guest graham laurie
through the royal family around the
world more than 20 years including
flying the coffin of princess diner back
after that horrible car crash in france
in 1997. he joins me now thank you so
much for coming in today it must have
brought back memories to you today i was
watching the coverage from edinburgh
airport and i felt for the guys there i
mean they've had probably three four
days to think about it i had about uh
eight hours and how nerve-wracking is it
when you're handed that kind of
responsibility
well i think because it's such a team
effort it involved i mean literally our
engineers
half an hour before we were due to take
off was the first we'd even thought
about bringing the body back because
normally it would have come back day
four
and um on you know the op order said day
four and so they had to rush and change
the fit of the fact we changed the
aircraft it was easier
and but when you're actually when you're
actually flying
something like the body of the princess
of wales the most famous woman in the
world after this horrendous crash which
the hot shot the world really what are
you feeling as you're in the cockpit i
think you know the shock was the thing
that day i mean it was with everybody um
the actual grief
came later i think but um
you couldn't forget it every when we got
airborne from villa kublai in paris with
the coffin
in the hold every single air trafficker
that we spoke to said please pass on our
condolences to the uh prince of wales
and
and go direct here well we were trying
to get the timing right to arrive at
seven o'clock in the evening and uh we
managed it um you you flew 2 200 trips
for the royal family including the queen
90 times
when you heard the queen had died what
were your feelings
very sad obviously um but what the
immediate thing that came to me how
lovely that two days before she was
working hard doing what majesty the duty
to the end and i think the fact that it
was then
relatively quick um you know i felt
after all she had done for this country
that was probably with the way she would
have liked to have gone and you were
king charles's personal pilot how do you
feel he's doing as king early days when
i saw that
speech he made on friday evening i
thought
there that's how he's going to be and i
think he's going to do a splendid job as
people are all saying about the long
apprenticeship but it's true though you
know he he's let's face it all the
government papers have been going
through him for 50 years so he knows
exactly how the country's run and what
happens you know there's nothing new
that you ought to be able to teach him
there and he's had plenty of time to
just think about what's going on there's
one little detail of what happened after
uh you flew back down as
coffin is you remember being invited to
see charles a high growth two days later
and the first thing he asked you was how
you and your family were coping yes in
fact that was when i'd um had the sight
incidentally not when i flew the office
back but yes that again shows the man he
was we got this phone call at eight
o'clock in the morning from the police
post at highgrove the prince of wales
would like to speak to you in uh half an
hour he came on the phone first question
how are your wife and family coping with
all the press coverage obviously and um
you know
i i eventually took the rap for that
quite rightly because i was captain of
the aircraft he did exactly as he was
told by me that day says a lot about him
i think and uh thank you very much for
your recollections greatly appreciate it
well that's up tonight thank you very
much emily adam i appreciate it we'll be
back tomorrow night that's it for me
tonight and the queen is tonight back at
buckingham palace for her last night
ever at that great palace for this great
moment
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that romaine had won and
at half past two quarter three after
nigel farage had already said he lost it
turned out he hadn't lost and it turned
out we were leaving the european union
so that was quite shocking
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zoro solomon queen
elizabeth's coffin is now lying in rest
at buckingham palace the coffin which
was flown from edinburgh earlier was
received by king charles the queen
consort camilla and other members of the
royal family the late queen will now
stay overnight at the palace before
being moved across london to westminster
hall tomorrow where she will lie in
state for four days before her funeral
on monday hundreds of thousands of
mourners are expected to pay their
respects with the government warning the
queue could exceed 30 hours
and the princess royal who accompanied
the queen's coffin on its journey from
scotland to london has issued a
statement paying tribute to her late
mother writing that it had been an honor
and a privilege to accompany her on her
final journeys that's all for now we'll
have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you